high gas prices encouraging more and
more people to go electric and under a
biden administration plan our state set
to receive nearly 38 million dollars to
expand our alternative fuel quarter
kirsten joy is now connecting with one
expert to discuss the current trends in
ev charging
we are now seeing some of the big
players wake up in addition to leader
tesla major automakers like gm and volvo
are making huge investments in the
production of evs how great to see ford
with the f-150 lightning the mustang
mackie i don't think they can build
enough but this momentum is at risk of
stalling roger atkins says if the
charging process does not become as easy
as possible he is the founder of
electric vehicles outlook in the uk also
an advisor to momentum dynamics he just
completed a north american tour sharing
more about wireless charging technology
that is currently being used in oslo and
sweden this whole principle of what they
call grazing rather than guzzling just
makes more sense imagine driving an
electric vehicle over a wireless
charging pad without having to lift a
finger or get out of the vehicle
momentum dynamics would like to make
this a reality for all the company is a
leader in wireless charging technology
it's found that the solution to range
anxiety isn't putting bigger batteries
into cars that can hold more charge it's
letting the charging infrastructure
itself contribute to extending the
driving range of vehicles the battery is
the biggest well certainly a big chunk
of the cost of an ev
if we can see this happen with cars if
we can have smaller batteries which cost
less we can bring the price of evs down
you know probably quicker than we would
have done
and deliver wireless charging you know a
little and often rather than having to
fill the whole thing up for hours
kirstjen joyce live local now